in meinem letzten Virtual Reality Video
war die Soundqualität ein bisschen
übersteuert
und dabei dem Video dann extrem viele
von euch kommentiert haben dass ich doch
bitte nicht so ins Mikrofon schreiben
soll habe ich mir gedacht dass wir heute
direkt zu gehen und da die ganzen albern
ist jetzt weg sind meine Damen und
Herren darf ich euch heute recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zum
Brandenburger ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
noch nicht so ganz worum es hier geht
allerdings befinden wir uns in
irgendeiner Bar die sehr ulkig aussieht
wir haben interessante Musik
[Musik]
amerikanisch
[Applaus]
so gefällt mir die Musik am besten so
oder so würde ich sagen schauen wir
erstmal wo wir sind ich denke mal
irgendwo in Amerika weil da steht police
station und die Schilder sind auch die
amerikanisch aus da steht auch Police
und Ali Happy Hour haben wir hier das
ganze Spiel ist auf englisch
dementsprechend denke ich mal irgendwie
New York oder so wir haben
Baseballschläger
[Musik]
zum Glück keiner gesehen ich kann mir
einen
Baseballschläger herausnehmen
[Musik]
es war nicht so gemeint
Dalai Lama Entschuldigung okay tschüss
besser ich glaube das ist ja oder nein
[Musik]
immer wenn ich einkaufen
wir können ein bisschen was anderes
machen oder so
[Musik]
Flaschen nehmen
aber ihr seid irgendwie alle ein
bisschen
Security unten übelster Bodybuilder okay
komm her der hat doch schon auf seinem
T-Shirt irgendwas mit Geld okay
[Musik]
nicht so gut geklappt hat würde ich
sagen folge mir bei dem nächsten Teil
und gehen hier vorne in den Fahrstuhl
rein wo wir
jetzt die elevator Boys verprügeln
müssen
[Musik]
ach oh mein Gott
ich bin jetzt hier auf seiner Fans die
war die haben auch diese
Aschenbecher
und Champagner
[Musik]
okay hier sind Tipps das ist einfach
Geld hier erreichen
nein
falsch geschrieben
[Musik]
oh mein Gott Alter es tut so weh so oder
so würde ich sagen wir waren jetzt schon
in der Bar da vorne also in dieser
ultigen New Yorker Bar wir sind nach
oben gefahren mit dem Fahrstuhl zum
Penthouse und haben jetzt noch das Taxi
da vorne und hier vorne so ein Clowns
Ding vielleicht auch da vorne hier
irgendwie so ein Cowboy Club ich bin
allerdings sagen wir gehen jetzt erstmal
zum Taxi weil ich nicht weiß ob wir
damit nach Hause fahren oder vielleicht
irgendwo anders hin wegen dem krassen
Club oder so
was hat das jetzt mit dem Flugzeug zu
tun
wir sind im Flugzeug
reden wir sind ja in Deutschland Flug so
erstmal haben wir ein bisschen
Champagner
jetzt können
wir hier volle Gläser wenn wir uns die
rein tippen oh lecker ausgezogen
[Musik]
Damen Schlagring Feuerzeug eine Zigarre
in Fächer oh mein Gott wir haben einen
Daumen oder so eine schaumstoffhand die
vorne haben man Apfel Getränk wir haben
Nüsse Alkohol ein Donut und ein Koffer
mein Freund
[Musik]
aussieht
hier vorne können wir unser unsere
Person glaube ich so ein bisschen
[Musik]
ich will dir ehrlich gesagt nicht
der sieht auch nicht so freundlich aus
ach du scheiße ach du grüne Leute jetzt
haben wir schon wieder ein Tanz im
Flugzeug ich will ich will gar keinen
Stress mit euch
da unten ach du Kacke Weg mit dir hey
ich gehe hier ganz schnell raus aber ich
glaube wir haben mit niemand mehr Stress
oh mein Gott ach wer ist sie denn
eigentlich
[Applaus]
komplett Stress gerade äh hier vorne ist
irgendwie
Schlagzeug hier um die Ecke okay hier
vorne ist schon Blut auf dem Boden mit
dem hat mir gerade Stress aber ich
glaube er hat schon wieder vergessen mit
seiner kleinen
Tourismus also hier muss man die ganzen
Sachen
oh mein Gott Alter
äh geht's anscheinend auch nicht los
[Musik]
ich laufe jetzt mal hier vorne rein ich
glaube aber in die kommen direkt in den
nächsten Flieger ach du scheiße ich
komme alle hinterher
[Musik]
nein
allerdings du dich an der Stelle den
drunken Simulator jetzt auch beenden
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann lasst
gerne einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video
da abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
Digger ist so